okay now there's a color line things I
want to say about the Sun or I'm not
gonna say them yet though I just want to
use this this as my argument for why
wherever you possibly can
don't use the sign rule right if you
have a choice because depending on the
information you've been given you might
not have to use the sign rule
what's the opposite it's the cosine rule
right so really quickly let's revise
this okay even though the cosine rule
tends to be learned at the same time as
the sine rule because you need the same
kind of knowledge to understand them I
think the cosine rule is best understood
in terms of Pythagoras well because I
wrote just Pythagoras on steroids that's
all this is
okay did you did you realize that think
about it what is my tires there can
someone stand it for me
okay you would usually say the normal
way we say is of medical a squared plus
B squared equals C squared I want to say
in Reverse right I'm gonna say in
Reverse and you'll see why in a second
okay this is actually the way that the
wording is said if you remember learning
the the sentence that Pythagoras's
theorem is it's the square of the
hypotenuse equals the sum of the squares
of the shorter sides okay so that's
Pythagoras but only works in
right-angled triangles the cosine rule
takes Pythagoras and it modifies it to
make it work in other trails because of
course what does the cosine will say
it's that's exactly the same way C
squared he keeps on going a squared plus
B squared and then it's got it's got an
extra bit on the side right - su a B cos
C now of course think about this right
if you were in a right angle triangle
Pythagoras right if you were in a right
angle triangle
see see see the C the hypotenuse right
so what's the angle that's opposite the
hypotenuse it's 90 degrees right it's 90
degrees and cos 90 is 0 so this
disappears in other words you have pike
of course you do all right but the idea
here is like this if you draw beneath
this for me a small writing triangle
just so we think illustrates okay so
this is our normal situation right for
Pythagoras C squared equals a squared
plus B squared but just think about
what's happening as this angle here
changes okay to starters
okay so our normal situation for
Pythagoras is the cause website this
theory over here C capital C is 90
degrees okay so this is my close graph
so we're on my graph am i I'm here right
90 degrees okay 90 Rees so you can see
this which is kind of like the
adjustment factor if you like this guy
is equal to zero right so when these
equal to just get Pythagoras well let's
just think about what happens man this
is this here is angle C let's think
about what happens as C changes for
instance what if we made C smaller what
if we made it smaller right
no I'm just going to juice them so if I
made C smaller so it's shrinking okay so
for something like this for instance
okay so imagine I still had the same a
right I just took to the dough but I
still got the same be okay but my angle
has gotten smaller and so what happens
to see in this case capital C is an
acute angle right it's a cute so can you
see I'm going this way right I went from
90 degrees that was my starting point
and now I'm going this way I'm in this
little area here okay so if capital C is
in this domain right then cause cqc it's
positive
you see cos C is positive so what I'm
doing is I take what I had before my
hypotenuse right and I'm taking what
taking away something positive that
makes sense because my angle is getting
smaller so the side that's opposite it
should also be getting smaller does that
make sense
you see that so as I go further and
further this way in fact like if I if I
may say like
okay like that can you see I'm
subtracting more and more and more
eventually like as I get to zero this
thing will be so big that it will cancel
out the whole side right well you just
go straight that's the first case if
capital C got little right
what if capital C got big what if you
take the same triangle and I lean this
is a over here if I lean it off to the
side right like that I've got the same a
the same be down here and now I have a
much much bigger angle for capital C
like that
so now capital C is obtuse right which
is somewhere on the graph that line over
here I die over here so cause of capital
C is negative some kind of double
negative here so you have C squared
equals what the hypotenuse is equal to
before this and then this is actually
going to be this whole red thing is
gonna be positive of course it's gonna
be positive because see that side the
hypotenuse is getting longer and longer
it's gonna stretch out okay so the
cosine rule is just Pythagoras on
steroids it's just adjusting for what
happens when you don't have a right
angle okay now you can see my graph
there right see my graphical pause
because cause doesn't have this problem
right cause doesn't intersect twice any
line I draw through there one two three
any line you like right it only
intersects with cosine once right so
it's not like you have another option
that you're missing another solution
that the calculator is not telling you
it's always going to tell you the one
and only solution that's correct
cosine can hand obtuse angles to you
where the sine will cut okay so if you
have a choice you should use the cosine
rule rather than the